I'm here today with Ben Shapiro,
about eight months ago,
wave came up to Toronto,
would gave a rousing talk and uh,
talk about political correctness at that
point,
credit,
politically pointed political talk and
how you got a couple of questions for
you.
One is what,
what,
what are you planning to do in 2018?
What do you want to see happen in 2018
personally?
And then what?
Like,
so what are you aiming at?
Why?
So I mean obviously I'm aiming it at
broadening the reach of the political
messages that I espouse and the messages
of,
of I think,
personal responsibility in virtue that
I,
that I tried to espouse.
I'm also working on a book that I'm
really interested in right now about the
roots of Western civilization.
What is that makes for a happier and
more fulfilled Western civilization?
What generates purpose for civilization
and for individuals and why it is that
we seem to have lost purpose because my
general theory is that the reason that
we're trying to murder each other
politically and the reason that we hate
each other so much is that there is a
purpose shaped hole in our heart that we
are now filling with anger,
tribal anger at each other.
Uh,
and I'm trying to trace back,
kind of backtrack and say,
okay,
where did,
where did we go wrong?
Where,
where was purpose?
It's sort of,
it's,
it's high watermark.
And why are we now at Loeb?
Okay.
One of the things that I found in the
discussions that I've had over the last
year,
especially the public discussions,
public lectures,
let's say,
is that it seems perfectly possible to
make a room go silent by speaking to,
especially if it's a room full of young
men by speaking to them about
responsibility of truth.
And this is really staggered me because
those are obviously saleable messages
now,
especially for someone who's rather
cynical about the fundamental nature of
human beings.
I'm not saying that I am,
but if you,
if you launched a business plan to the
typical observers and said,
well,
I'm going to base up public movement on
the adoption of access,
responsibility and the requirement to
speak the truth,
and that's going to become hyper
popular.
The probability that people would agree
that that's a possibility.
It's pretty much zero.
And so I've been thinking that we've
spoken about rights for so long and
spoken about freedoms for so long,
let's say since the early sixties,
just essentially speaking,
we've actually left a conceptual whole
inner culture and that seems to be akin
to,
to the point that you're making with
regards to this book and now you,
you,
you mentioned responsibility and why
that specifically?
Well,
I think that what you're talking about
is exactly right.
People in the West have seemed to pose,
writes in,
in direct opposition to duties.
So,
uh,
the American founding particularly was
obsessed with this idea of,
of rights and individual rights,
but there was also this corresponding
idea of duties that's very clear in
founding thinking.
George Washington talks about duty.
Benjamin Franklin talks about duty.
The idea was that duty was to be
socially generated,
not by government,
but by,
by society itself,
like small communities,
by churches,
by your family,
and that that would fill the gap that
allowed you to actually have a
functioning society of rights,
but we seem to have left duty completely
behind now.
It's just all about the right to not
about the duty and what's happened is
that that's collapsed in on itself
because the society of only right to
know duties ends up generating raw
generating duties masquerading as
rights,
right?
Positive rights that are actually not
right at all.
There are me imposing a duty on you in
order to further my own perception of my
rights.
And that's I think where we've been
going and it's in.
It's a dark place and it creates an
enormous amount of opposition.
But when you say Jordan,
when you,
when you talk about the fact that people
would not have thought of building a
movement on notions of truth and
responsibility,
that's because I think for a long time
people just took it for granted that we
all agreed on these things.
Um,
but there's been an actual forcible
counter movement for generations now
against both truth and responsibility.
The idea that there is no objective
truth,
it's socially defined.
We can make it up as we go along.
There's no t los rev.
I talk a lot in the new book about,
about a teleological way of thinking.
This idea that you actually have a
purpose for which you were created and
that it's your job to fulfill that
purpose and that's completely been left
by the wayside.
So there's no truth,
there is no capacity.
Even write the scientific materialist
worldview actually robs you have the
capacity to even change yourself.
Right?
The studies that I've seen suggests that
if you believe in a certain form of
determinism,
if you believe in hard determinism,
you're less likely to go out and
actually change your life and make it
better because you buy into your own
philosophy.
And I think that as a side sort of
bought into that,
that we're all victims of our own
biology.
Victims of own raise victims were on
ethnicity or our situation and there's
no way for us to get out of that.
So we may as well throw up our hands or
at least give the power to the only
thing that can change things,
which is this,
which is this massive collective that
comes in and is the boot stomping on the
human face forever.
Well,
there's also the strange misapprehension
I think with regards to the nature of
rights,
because as far as I can tell,
I mean rights rights are a multifaceted
phenomenon,
but I think the least metaphysical claim
that you can make about rights is that
if I have a right,
then that brings with it a parallel
responsibility,
not only to myself to act in a manner
that is in accordance with that,
right,
whatever that happens to be,
but I also have a responsibility.
Is the right is universal to act in a
certain manner towards you.
And so because there is no difference
between rights and responsibilities,
fundamentally they're just mirror images
of one another.
Now that that's to say nothing about
their potential metaphysical orange and
I don't want to talk about that,
but it doesn't seem to me to be
logically 10 bubbles have an incident
conversation about rights without having
a parallel conversation about
responsibility.
So there's a logical flow and that
leaves that gap that needs to be filled.
And then the other thing that's occurred
to me is that the,
the genuine meaning in lights,
and I do believe that likes has a
genuine meaning.
I think I can make that claim without
even making it metaphysical,
although I don't mind the metaphysical
addition to it.
Um,
it seems to me that almost all the
things that people find meaningful in
life that aren't merely impulsive
pleasure,
which of course create thrown
entanglements,
have to do with the voluntary adoption
of responsibility.
So families like that.
Okay.
So,
all right,
so then,
okay,
so here's,
here's the next question.
What do you think it is?
It's driven our loss and of that half of
the conversation,
what's happened?
So I,
I think that this has been basically a
200 year movement that first manifested
itself in Europe.
And it's finally reaching American
shores about 100 years later,
which seems to be the pattern.
All the bad stuff from Europe hits
Europe about 50 to 100 years before it
hits here and now it comes here.
I think that what happened here is that
the enlightenment mentality was built on
certain fundamental premises,
including the use of human reason,
the capacity for free will and all of
that in turn rested on assumptions about
the universe,
including the idea that the universe has
a discoverable design that we can
actually find and pursue and that in
doing so,
we will find happiness.
The Aristotelian idea of happiness is
very much bound up with the idea of you
fulfilling your lowe's.
The Judeo Christian idea of happiness is
you fulfilling God's purpose for you.
There was always this idea of a higher
purpose that you were seeking.
And I think what happened is that the,
the,
the enlightenment project,
which started off in an attempt really
in the 13th century by people like
Aquinas,
my monities to unite religion and
science fell apart when they started to
divide the two.
Instead of it's we're,
we're seeking the same thing.
Religion and science are both seeking a
universal truths that can be applicable
to our own lives and make us more
fulfilled.
The project of science became to destroy
one pole to destroy religion,
and then by doing that,
science almost turned in on itself.
Reason almost eight itself.
So I think reason basically turned into,
okay,
we're going to follow to the logical end
point.
All of the,
all the nonreligious bases of,
of human thought.
And once you do that,
it's very difficult not to fall into a.
So a sort of self refuting trap about
human thought.
You're just a set of neurons that are
firing neurons don't have
responsibility.
Your dog doesn't have responsibility.
Do you have responsibility?
Uh,
you are a product of your environment,
your biology.
Does that carry with it?
Any sort of moral responsibility,
you don't have the capacity to choose if
you don't have the capacity to choose.
How do you have moral responsibility?
I debated Sam Harris on particularly
this issue and I thought that actually
the most telling point of the debate and
discussion was not anything the two of
us said it was a woman who got up at the
very end instead of Sam.
I totally agree with you.
There's no free will in the hard sense.
You can't make any sense you.
There is no choice other than to write
you.
You will have to do this just driven by
your biology and environment.
But I have a five year old son.
What do you want and what,
what should I say to him?
And Sam basically said,
lie basically said,
well,
tell him that he's capable of making a
choice.
And that's the truth about civilization.
Either you believe that's a lie and
you're actively engaging in Plato's good
lie basically,
or your or you have to believe in free
will.
And I don't think,
I don't think the capacity to choose and
the capacity to self better,
uh,
is,
is a lie.
I think that people do have the capacity
to do that.
I think even Sam believes that,
but he refuses to acknowledge it because
otherwise I don't think he would be in
the educational position that he is.
Right.
He spends his life trying to educate
people so that that's.
It's all weird.
I mean,
I actually said in the,
in the discussion,
why are we all in this auditorium?
We were just sort of predestined by the
universe to be in this auditorium at a
certain time.
Like,
do you feel fulfilled by that?
If so,
you really have no choice in the matter.
Well,
one of the things that bothered me about
the new atheist types and the hyper
rationalist is that there,
as far as I can tell their conduct is
performative contradiction.
They say they believe certain things,
but they don't act that way.
And,
and in my sense,
because I'm an existentialist at heart,
is that what you believe is what you act
out,
what you say might be in accordance with
that and it might not,
but,
and,
and there's no reason to assume that
your beliefs are transparent to yourself
regardless of your plate.
And so I also don't see any evidence
whatsoever that the society can exist
that functions over any reasonable
period of time,
in any reasonable manner without
predicating itself on the beliefs that
people are both capable of freewill am,
that they're responsible.
And so the fact that it seems to be
impossible to build a functioning
society or even functioning dyadic
relationships for that matter in the
absence of the presupposition of free
will and the capacity for voluntary
change indicates to me some evidence for
the existence of those capacities.
And you have to be a staggeringly
cynical person to think that no,
we just have to believe that that's true
even though it's a lie and predicate or
cultures or not.
I mean that's first of all I know,
I think it's a weak claim.
I don't think that it's also not the
rock upon which you want to fall into
your culture.
So one of the things that struck me
about the mythological stories that
aren't immersed myself in is that
there's always three.
There's always three prime characters in
it.
Ms Dot logical story.
There's culture,
right?
So that's the great father,
let's say.
And many mythological guises and there's
nature that's the great mother and so
you can say that that's the biology and
society of the modern scientist,
but then there's the independent
individual as a causal force who has a
nature that enables,
enables choice and free will in all of
those things.
And that that independent third factor
is something like the logos that gives
rise to being at the beginning of time,
right?
The cast that calls order fourth out of
chaos.
And the fact that we can't account for
that scientifically.
Although I don't think we can deny it
either,
doesn't mean that it doesn't exist.
Yeah,
I totally agree with that.
And of course I enjoy maps of meaning.
So I'm pretty familiar with the
terminology that you use because I've
read your book,
but I think that there's this idea that
you can find meaning in a meaningless
universe that we're just meatballs
wandering through space with a little
bit of sentience.
Uh,
understanding that where our meatballs
wandering through space,
I have a hard time building any sort of
system on that and the refusal of the
new atheist to even recognize that the
morality that they promulgated right,
the trip that they have on religion
typically is that religion is barbaric
and backwards and promulgates all sorts
of horrible moral values that with which
they disagree and what they refuse to
acknowledge that their moral values are
predicated within that system,
right?
For the vast majority of human time,
the values that they are espousing or
not,
not only not universal,
they're not even minority valleys.
They didn't exist for the vast majority
of human time.
They are absolute creations of the Judeo
Christian system that is combined with a
Greek reason to come up with what we
have today and this is essentially the
theory that I have come up with is that,
and this is the thesis of the book that
I'm writing right now,
which is that in order for an in order
for society or an individual to feel
fulfilled,
you basically have to have four things.
You have to have an individual purpose.
You have to feel like you have a purpose
in the world.
You personally have a purpose in the
world.
You have to feel like you have an
individual capacity.
You have to feel like you are capable of
pursuing that with alacrity.
Uh,
you have to have a communal purpose.
You have to feel like you alone with
others are pursuing a higher goal.
That means something and you have to
have communal capacity.
So a system that has been built that
allows that community to activate when
it needs to activate and back off so
that the individual can exist in that
vacuum and we have torn away at all the
roots of those things because all of
those things that I think the apotheosis
of the.
I think the apex of modern thought was
basically the unfulfilled but universal
theories of the American founding
fathers,
I think is about as good as it got a
internal governmental theory.
I don't think it's gotten better since
then.
I think that it's been extended more
broadly.
I think the universalism that they were
implying has now been applied in many
ways and that's a great thing.
Right.
Did the founders obviously still held
slaves?
Many of them,
but they're,
their principals were not in favor of
slavery.
Uh,
so the principles that they espoused
were based on,
again,
these two competing poles that are,
that are constantly intention with one
another and this sort of Leo Strauss he
intention with one another between
reason and revelation,
the Judeo Christian tradition and the
Greek tradition of reason and the tug
and back and forth is what allows you to
have one foot in rights and one foot in
duties.
So we really good to have a lengthy
conversation about this at some point
because there's some things in here that
really have to be delving deeply like
the day you have to find your own
purpose.
Argument was one that was put forth
third stroke and after he announced the
death of God,
he said that people would have to resale
you good and evil and to come up with
their own definitions of what
constituted morality.
And like the Nietzschean criticism of,
of Christianity is about as deep as it
got with the possible exception of
Dostoevsky.
But there's,
one of the things I really liked about
Carl Young,
and it's really struck me as,
as is irrefutable,
is use fundamental response to nature,
was that,
well,
um,
let's,
let's take the argument of the death of
God to its logical conclusion.
And then let's the idea that human
beings have to be the creator of the
creators of their own systems,
of meaning.
You idea.
And this was also the case for the other
side,
psychoanalyst Swiss.
That's just palpably false because it
turns out that you're not the sort of
creature that can create your own
meaning.
You're the sort of creature that has to
discover the meaning that already exists
in coded within you.
And part of that is that you're not your
own slaves.
And so,
so it's a critique not only of the idea
that you can,
will your own destiny in its entirety
while completely ignoring the fact that
you have in nature,
but it's also a profound critique of the
socialist Utopian ideas that human
beings can be mold in any way that they
see fit.
And so young subjection was something
like,
well,
try to generate a meeting on your own,
out of nothing,
and then try to force yourself to follow
it and see how far you get.
What you'll find is that you rebelled
your own nature,
rebels in every possible way against the
arbitrary imposition of a certain of
just any old moral framework on the
manner in which you're going to conduct
yourself.
And so
yeah,
I think this is potentially it's,
it's such a deep critique and I think
that it's.
It's so telling because what we've come
up with is that the substitute for what
you're talking about,
which is this acknowledgement that there
is a universal purpose,
that we ought to be aspiring to discover
that it's actually out there.
There's a purpose out there and it's our
job to uncover it as opposed to self
creating it.
That that is a really deep divide in in
America.
I think in the West generally because
what people have said is,
well,
okay,
we finally realized that we do need this
thing called purpose,
right?
We can't just be a hedonist,
solve the time,
drugs and sex aren't going to cut it.
We're actually going to need to come up
with some purpose for Hydrus,
right,
but well,
but we're not going to be able to,
but but at the same time,
we don't want a government or a society
or a church or a community forcing down.
It's universal perception of values on
us and so therefore are our happy medium
is going to be you define your own,
your own freedom.
You define your own,
your own rights,
and you define your own view of the
universe.
Well,
that is always going to just devolve
into this pathetic sort of solipsism
that can never be escaped from and it
doesn't provide happiness anyway.
I mean the people who quote unquote
define their own meaning are some of the
least happy people that you will ever
meet because they don't believe that
their incontinence with anything larger.
If you're.
If you're looking into your self,
your self is not that big.
There's not that much there,
right?
There has to be something beyond you.
Whether you find it in God or whether
you find it in in a community or a
nature,
there has to be something that speaks to
you beyond the guts that exist inside
you where you're just examining your own
intestines
to that you can make a strong scientific
case.
This is something I'd never gone to in
my discussions with Sam Harris,
is you could make a strong scientific
case for the reality of meaning as an as
an for.
Let's just call it for the reality of
meetings.
You might think about it as a
psychological reality,
but you can think about it as a
metaphysical or a biological reality too
because as far as I can tell and there's
good neurological evidence for this.
Your brain is adapted to two modes of
being and one mode of being is that mode
that obtains when you're where you know
what you're doing and you know what's
going on so you could call that explored
territory that's safe and there's
another motive being that is that which
obtains and when you don't know what's
going on.
When you're an unexplored territory,
you can say,
well,
animals since the beginning of time have
adapted to some combination of explored
an unexplored territory and that's
roughly a kid to known and not known,
which I think is what symbolized in knee
and Yang symbols and as far as I can
tell,
the sense of meaning that people
experience that spontaneous and deep is
an indication that they're functioning
well,
unexplored territory,
but simultaneously increasing their
capacity to deal with unexplored
territory so it's like the zone of
proximal development or even the flow
states that chicks at Harley is talked
about,
but see the best thing to be is where
things are going well for you,
but also where you're expanding the
capacity of things to go well for you
simultaneously and then you can add to
that the fact that that's not going to
be solipsistic because we live in a
social world.
If I'm pursuing something that's deeply
meaningful,
then what if?
If,
if things are constructed,
fortunately then I'm going to be
pursuing something that's very good for
me now and me later in knee,
deep into the future.
At the same time,
I'm pursuing something that's good for
you now and you later down deep into the
future.
Now I believe that that sense of of deep
engagement that helps people in
fortunate periods of their lives is
actually a neurological signals that
that the layers of being are stacked on
top of one another properly and that
you're oriented properly within the and
that it's the,
it's a c to me,
I've,
I've often thought that the most real
thing is paid and then you might say,
well,
if there's an antidote to pain,
that would be something that would be
even more real than paint.
And it seems to me that the sense of
meaning that I'm talking about pure
that's associated with this,
with this sense of ultimate
responsibility is an antidote to paint
and therefore it's something that's
real.
I don't see anything.
You can make a metaphysical claim about
that and that's perfectly reasonable,
but you don't have to.
You can make a bloody hardcore
scientific claims for that and I think
it's extremely difficult to refute
why you have it.
I tend to agree with that and I think
that you know,
you,
you referencing the the flow state and
that's something that where we are
happiest right from scientific research
isn't that flow state and that flow
state is exactly what we're talking
about now.
This,
this feeling that you have mastery over
your capacity to explore the unexplored
and that the unexplored is worth is
worth exploring.
Right?
I mean that's the other thing is that
what drives you to to explore the
unexplored.
It's not just that you get up in the
morning and you feel like laundering
outside into the forest.
There's some of that,
but I think some of it is that you feel
like there's a natural necessity for you
as a human being to do that.
There's a moral duty for you to try and
conquer new worlds and adding the moral
layer.
More of the moral impetus on top of.
I just have a decision to,
to,
to go out and explore territory is what
I think allows civilization to,
to create rather than destroy,
and I've talked a lot on my show about a
male male toxicity.
You know what people have to the toxic
masculinity and all this knowledge and
and what what and what not.
The binary nature,
I think of human beings particularly
men,
is that men have a little boy who's a
year and a half old and he's either.
He's either building a stack of blocks
where he's destroying the stack of
blocks.
There is no in between and so if you
are.
If you're exploring unexplored
territory,
there are only two ways to deal with
that.
One is to actually take a fire and set
it in the unexplored territory or the
other is to cultivate that unexplored
territory and adding that moral layer of
it's your job to forge out into the
universe and make that cultivated toward
towards.
You.
Bring that into the known that a adding
that moral dimension is I think what
both the Greeks and Judeo Christian
tradition are about and I think it's
more frequent Judeo Christian,
but the idea that there is a god worth
exploring and that God has reached down
demand and uplifted him is is I think
relevant to jail Christian religion and
is really the essence of Judaeo
Christian religion.
If you look at polytheism,
that notion that you're out there to try
and understand God,
it doesn't.
It doesn't exist in polytheistic
religion.
The notion that you're supposed to look
beyond your.
You're supposed to look beyond yourself
to a broader understanding of the
universe.
Know you were subject to forces in the
Right,
and those were represented by the
different Gods,
not this idea that there's a universal
system that's that's at least partially
knowable that if you spend your life
trying to investigate and live in
continents with you will be happier.
That's a lot closer to the Greek system,
which is why you ended up with this
common idea of the logos that you talk
about being in the book of John,
but also really springing from from
Greek thought.
I mean that's,
that's,
that's the idea there,
right?
Right,
right,
right.
Yes.
It's an unbelievably brilliant
synthesis.
No,
you,
you touched on the idea of cultivation,
so I wanted to ask you both dot.
I'm going to Amsterdam to talk to this
event at this event sponsored by a group
called the Dutch law and,
and that's going to happen to seven
January 19th and go got about 2000
people attending this event and it's
scoring to be a national discussion
about a Datsun European identity and
immigration.
And so in principle it can be a big deal
and one of the things I've been
meditating on is what it is that Western
civilization got right.
And so the first thing I think is that
we got the idea of the logos,
right?
That's a big deal to sovereignty of the
individual and the sovereignty and the
necessity for respect of the capacity of
the exploring individual to conquer new
territory and make it habitable.
We got that right and so and and I mean
fundamentally.
Right?
But then that seems also to me to tie
interestingly into the idea of property
rights because the fundamental Marx's
claim,
there's a number of them,
but one of the most fundamental claims
is that property is in some sense fast
and so that might even mean the property
that you accrued as a consequence of
being successful and I think it might be
worth giving the devil his due and say,
well,
are there conditions under which my
occupation of a space to the exclusion
of you isn't merely theft?
And the idea cultivation I think is
exactly the right answer to that is that
the point is for each of us to allow the
other to occupy a particular place in
time,
in the hopes that we'll each take care
of it for our own benefit and for the
benefit of others.
And then what happens is that everyone
wins.
Yeah,
and this is a very obviously lockean
idea,
right?
This idea of what makes property
worthwhile and property rights
worthwhile as you mix your labor with
the land and you cultivated it,
which is why lot specifically talks
about the notion of adverse possession,
right?
If I own a piece of property and I just
decided to leave it trashed somewhere
and then someone comes in and cultivates
the property,
even though I own the property,
I should have a good legal case to
actually make against that owner because
I'm not cultivating the property.
The idea being that cultivation and use
of the land is actually your individual
duty.
It's your individual duty and it's also
your communal duty.
So yeah,
I think that the moral legitimacy of
property rights is it,
you know,
in,
in locks thought particularly is very
much tied to cultivation and your
personal stake in what you've done with,
with the property that you own.
Again,
it's exactly your point that there's a
mix of rights and duties.
Property rights are linked to duties.
It's not just property own.
Okay.
So maybe we can close with this.
You know,
the,
the idea of a garden was very
interesting to me and of course the
natural environment of the human being
is the garden according to Genesis,
right?
It's the garden of Eden and I thought
for a long time,
well,
why is it a garden?
And the answer to that is that a garden
is the optimal juxtaposition of nature
and culture,
right?
So a garden is nature blooming of its
own accord,
but tended very carefully and so then
the rule would be something like you're
allowed to,
you're allowed to own something,
you have the right to own something,
you have the privilege to own something
if what you're doing is transforming
into a bountiful garden.
That's exactly right.
I think that's true and I think that's
true in every area of,
of a successful life.
It's true how you raise your children.
Yeah,
you lose the right to raise your
children properly if you're raising your
children improperly.
I think it's true of marriage.
Marriages break down when you don't call
today,
and cultivation is the,
the,
the ultimate human need is cultivation.
And when we cultivate,
whether it's in the realm of knowledge
or science or whether it's in the realm
of religion and relationships than we
are happier and when we don't cultivate
and we,
uh,
when we deprive ourselves of the
capacity and both the capacity and the
purpose of cultivation,
then everything falls into anarchy then.
Then just through entropy,
everything will fall apart I think.
Okay.
So the right objection to privileges
cultivation.
So like I'm not privileged on
cultivating.
I liked that.
I liked that a lot.
Yeah.
What's necessary to get to grip these
things by the neck,
you know.
And so.
Okay.
That's good.
Well look,
thanks very much for talking to me.
I hope we get a chance to talk again in
the relatively near future because
there's some things we could really sort
out.
I think
that'd be great.
I'd really appreciate it.
I'm big fan of your work,
obviously.
Yeah.
Phoenix mutual.
Thanks so much.
Good talking to you.
Happy New Year.
Right?
You too.
Bye.